hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see olympus
has fallen so let's hang out after the
White House is overtaken and the
president has been kidnapped disgraced
former presidential guard Mike Benning
has to save the president and the United
States by becoming John McClane and
killing a bunch of Koreans yes reason to
see number one Gerard Butler this man
can finally do an American accent with
his whole mouth yes he doesn't talk to
the right side of his face anymore mr.
president five minutes sir gaming ma'am
Merry Christmas Mike Mustang this is Big
Top bringing out the full package it's
it's incredible and he also he's gonna
he's gonna pretty good he's got a pretty
good American accent he does have a good
American accent it's much better than
you know Your Honor I Lolo abiding
citizen this is the ugly truth yeah you
know he's definitely improved an accent
but not just the accent he does a great
job in the performance actually he's the
best part of this movie is the reason to
see this movie he is more badass than
some of the action in this phone yeah
you have a feeling that at certain times
the actions only bad ass because he's
there yeah this is like Thank You Gerard
Butler some of his delivery is better
than a lot of the action it's pretty
crazy how he is more captivating the
watch 40 commandos breach the gate 28
who left
can we trust him with all due respect
I'm the best hope you've got is he
surprisingly in like especially the
first half he doesn't have that many
scenes they they take him out of a lot
of the movie it's not like you're
spending your whole time with him as
your only protagonist but you you kind
of wish that Gerard Butler was the main
focus cuz how much fun to watch and at
the beginning of this movie I mean they
they show it in the trailer he fails to
save the president's wife
so there's a real story of redemption
here for the guy and uh although i
didn't find myself strongly rooting for
him and that wasn't Gerard Butler's
fault that was more fault on the story I
did want and to get his Redemption
really bad he brings a certain amount of
depth to the role like they don't do a
ton of character expositional stuff but
you just believe that there's life going
on inside this guy's head you know so
it's he brought a lot more to the Care
Act it's it's a three-dimensional
performance Oh reason to see number two
its action packed I like the first half
of this movie's violence I did because
there's a certain sense of realism
behind it there's a lot of danger to it
there's a certain level of suspense
because the first act is mainly setting
up the characters which I ain't like I
really appreciated that about this film
so when the action comes in it's like
you're really concerned for these people
and they this is a this isn't something
like pg-13 [ __ ] like yes citizens
are getting murdered what and that's
that's one thing i'm happy they did is
they stuck to the r rating Jerry is
happy they murdered citizens and I kill
Maz what I say no anyway better uh I
like that they kept it are because they
could say things that people would
actually say in situations like these
and they can some of the more surprising
things in this movie came from that
freedom the r-rating gave them there's
an interrogation scene where Gerard
Butler's trying to get information out
of two guys he captures and that was a
pretty sweet scene yeah and it's pretty
intense and you wouldn't have seen that
the pg-13 movie but what I will say is
that when the story starts to become
weak the action stops becoming impactful
but it is action-packed throughout you
know there's definitely it's definitely
not without its action scenes it does
flirt with an exploitation you vibe
because there's some act there's some of
the action scenes and there are certain
bits of violence that are really sort of
uncomfortable to watch in of the a
brutal sort of way so it does kind of
skate between you know like really big
[ __ ] like we're destroying all of
Washington and then you know like
tortures reason to see number three the
supporting cast what they did with most
of the supporting cast
is they gave a lot of depth to them
there's a solid supporting cast in this
movie you got Morgan Freeman as the
presidential speaker you got melissa leo
has an important political woman then
you got aaron eckhart as the president
yeah and you got a Robert Forrester as
the general so there's a solid
supporting cast in this movie so a lot
of the supporting cast backed up would
you're our Butler strong performance
it's a very well-rounded cast in general
yeah Oh Dylan McDermott Center and dylan
mcdermott sin it too good to have to see
him again reason to see number 4 it's
better than a good day to die hard a
good day to die hard sucked this people
are saying is a replica of the diehard
formula which it is it is but it's
better than the preview the latest
diehard installment yeah this would have
been a great plot for for die hard 5 so
let's move on to the reasons not two
seasons not reason not to see number one
the tone my biggest issue with this
movie is the tone yeah the tone in this
film is so like what are they going for
exactly well the ache is it jumps around
it's it's like half of it wants to be
die hard you know like one-liners and
fight actually have fun actions like
that's like one thing this film is
trying to do and then okay no you go oh
well Jimmy it's like the first 30
minutes was a whole different beast from
that thing because it's like they're
destroying the [ __ ] out of the capital
of America and that stuff always gets
under my skin and kind of scares me so
like that was really intense and then
you have all this other stuff where
they're like beating the [ __ ] out of
people and it feels like an exploitation
movie because of how sort of reels yeah
freak out song that's what I mean I
didn't know if I wanted to be like this
patriotic serious phone where you're
cheering for America and stuff or if
they wanted to just be a straightforward
action flick so a lot of its patriotic
moments to me didn't quite hit the mark
it seemed a little cheesy and you know
man if the tongue was better we would
have been cheering for gerard butler at
times like there are moments in this
phone i saw us with a packed house and I
saw the call people were cheering
throughout the call
all this movie people should have been
clapping at certain moments there are
moments where you're like yeah why is
that one applying reason not to see
number two cinematography I don't hate
the cinematography in this film no
there's some good moment yeah but a lot
of it takes place with gerard butler
sneaking around the White House and
honestly sometimes it's very difficult
to see what's going on yes so dark that
it kind of is there's especially the
fight scenes are like what the [ __ ] is
going on right now for the first 15 or
so minutes of this movie I was saying
they're going like is it are they using
a dim bulb or something yeah that's
wrong with the projector like and then
hear you say that I guess it must just
be a dimly lit movie I guess it's a dark
story and I was probably trying to
resemble the darkness of the characters
are I get what they're going for but
when you turn off the lights I mean come
on yeah I've got to be able to see
what's going on just a little bit reason
not to see number three the script ok so
like we've seen earlier the characters
are are well written they are well
written their three-dimensional but as
the phone progresses especially once we
enter into the last half it starts to
become a generic action flick it seems
like they stopped caring about exploring
the characters because the first act of
this movie you really get to know the
characters you even understand a lot of
the supporting characters but they seem
to stop giving a [ __ ] about that as the
film progresses yeah it's like the
script does these things where every now
and again these things will happen it
seemed just really convenient or
coincidental and then they kind of took
me out of the movie and certain
characters make decisions that you kind
of wonder why all right so after talking
about this movie I guess I'll have to
give my bottom line on it Ryan's
consensus I would have to say that there
are some strong reasons to see olympus
has fallen there are some strong reasons
to see olympus has fallen yeah at the
end of the day it's an action movie and
if you're just looking for action it's
certainly actually packed even though i
don't personally love it
he's consensus I gotta say Gerard Butler
is the reason to see this movie Gerard
Butler's the reason to see Olympus has
fallen he steals the show from me um you
know there's some effective stuff in
there it's alright alright guys thanks
for checking out our video please go
ahead and tell us your reasons to see or
not to see olympus has fallen we will go
ahead and reply back to whatever you got
to say and if you want to check out my
straight to the point review of Olympus
has fallen if you want to know what the
difference is just listen to the title
it's straight to the point of Olympus is
falling go ahead and click on the link
right here and if you want to see more
episodes of reasons to see click the
link right who and if you want to get
updated every time a new movie review
was out subscribe subscribe or Gerard
Butler will punch you in the face yeah
or like stab you in the knees and kill
your friend or something yeah stab you
in the brain yeah he said he will do to
someone in the movie yeah you did yeah
just click on the box and then your
computer will explode it Wow terrorist
theme Jerry yeah no that's good yeah
good the government is gonna arrest us
once they certainly gerard butler and
the terrorists will kill you is what i'm
trying to say everyone will kill you
know what is on your side yeah literally
it's you against the world this is some
eagle eye [ __ ] right here now i know you
definitely want to subscribe
you